[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of wrists of fury I'm Kelsey cook and
today I'm so excited we got two of the
most requested guests ever please give
it up for the sky brother yeah excited
we don't know what's in store for us but
we know it's not gonna be good
you said ahead of time that you're both
terrible oh I'm terrible at this
I wouldn't say terrible but certainly
not at the level to even come close to
the risks of fury that exists across the
table for our like my wrists of
consternation yeah constipation you're
upset about something you're frustrated
but they're not furious it's not like
that well no yeah well is there like any
strategy between who's playing offense
who's playing defense there's no stress
I mean I have a little bit of a strategy
to play defense I don't think it'll work
but I I mean I don't want to give it
away but I have a learner
it's staggered the guy's staggering
cover as much ground as he cover as much
ground as you can stagger and then pray
I mean I do a lot we do a lot of pray we
do a lot of praying to Jesus even though
we're Jews well so we did a prayer
circle for like an hour before we can
just to get ready we could be delivered
to victory I doubt it and if we aren't
then that's proven away what if we did
it's not going to have but what if we be
listening if we won't quit they should
have to quit the podcast if we be to
joke if we don't win it is proof that
Jesus was not real let's go okay here we
go YouTube comments get ready so you
guys have to podcast you have dumb
people town yes and view from the cheap
seats yeah because you used to have an
ESPN show called cheap seats yeah you
guys are big sports people yeah yeah
love sports and I've always I can't
believe we never did a foosball game on
cheap seats we did miniature golf and
there was a husband and wife
miniature golf team dick and Evelyn
Florin they were in like they're in the
Hall of Fame is it your parents in the
whole thing my mom is in the first ball
Hall of Fame
this is her but I thought you were gonna
be like world always wonder here next
week
wait that's her this is my mom's book
it's the world table soccer Almanac okay
okay table soccer that makes me want to
punch your mama sagres like calling
mcdonalds a restaurant it's not a
restaurant if the table is nailed to the
floor right we are playing soccer but
with sports guys you would appreciate it
I know for four to call this table
futsal yeah this is why because it's all
about control not until you see us play
then you'll really regret it show ever
[Music]
okay so would you like to start with the
ball so I have a question for you why
don't you put it in through the side so
actually now the way you start
regulation play is you place it on your
v bar you ask your opponent
are you ready they say ready and then
you have to touch two men wait a second
and then because it's it prevents people
from just being like you know and like
going crazy so yeah so my question is
the record I blocked that I just want
the record
even though she was joking you live
blocks it away her does your mom hold it
over your dad that she's in the Hall of
Fame and he isn't well they're divorced
okay she does she married someone else
who is in the Hall of it okay but you
know they met through foosball they
lasted ten years I think that's kind of
amazing run for foosball that's like a
long-distance ball game ever so I'm
gonna let you start first
yes I love about food as well still
employing the abacus score no one no
one's done a digital scoring system yeah
by the way we only go to five you borrow
those ten on here just good hey man
that's the world of table soccer can I
be okay so we're good here all right
good okay can I be Neymar and what
Neymar he's a soccer player who you play
soccer not on tables right okay all
right so you be who you are you ready I
am ready
okay so I've never been more ready one
two three run around blocking your
cirrhotic yes oh good luck city bro I'm
sorry I'm sorry I know you guys are
coming in cold like I said I'm like a
sensitive person on Twitter I'm blocking
everything yeah
so good I didn't couldn't block that
comment why do I get to start with
because you just go bro that was not
yeah she was not expecting that I think
maybe you guys aren't as bad as you told
me over and if we go a little bit of a
mind game
we're not Josh wolf but God bless Joshua
now what happens when this happens to
the corner Oh
total score on yourself nice jack oh
yeah we're gonna get some like twin
fighting back and forth I love that you
were defending the goal from here yeah
well my god did it go in there
no so I did work I would put in work in
it do you guys play sports together
often we play tennis we play golf and we
play basketball together but you know
and played like on softball teams and
haven't played tons of sports we were
kids
Oh Jay that one that almost scores I
don't freak me out a little bit how does
it work when you guys play together or
do you guys kill each other where are
you know each other
did you see what we just said to each
other yeah nice we're awful to each
other we're angry
that wasn't I'm gonna put that on him
where's your five guy yeah no I mean
we're terrible to each other we yell at
each other we blame each other because
we feel like on some level we can we are
the reason we that was so strong and
came back out of the goal how does that
feel
you know we have no illusions that we
were gonna do we're so Tara fact that I
got shot on the goal yeah me is layup
but of course shock of course you missed
it but like we'll put the type of
seriously yeah doing anything like a
married couple
we're like your parents stayed together
exactly I'm sorry too soon enough I love
that yours are roasting I'm like your
parents like
your parents meter us or unknown your
parents we're bad at foosball and
neither of us can leave both of us all
right come on here we go and we are
willing to play with each other's balls
okay come on
so just a heads up it's it's four zeros
no we know this did I make it
yep okay nice one Jake did good work we
were like two people who just saw up
close magic I don't like to people what
we're like two guys on Maury Povich who
found out that they both weren't the
father
okay let it be known that that score
came from her missing and going all the
way back down neither of us shot that
sometimes but sometimes victory is
getting out of the way that's right
just like your mother - why your
champion who created a champion you
deserved a lot better and I'm glad you
got sorry I'm sorry sir probably happier
at this point are we proud of her for
which that she's made something out of
her life yeah out of this this is
amazing okay keel right Oh take your
point by the way oh I'm sorry
boom this happens every match when I go
okay so just so you guys know it's for
you and then I scrap myself it happens
sure that fail yeah all right so I get
it because Oh cuz you just got yeah yeah
she's gonna good okay are you ready yes
I finish this okay you know who's coming
dad you had both along here all right
now what so now we reset okay I know
we're gonna go to round two
[Music]
we're gonna make things a little more
interesting they're gonna shake up the
usual game so you guys pick one ball one
for the two of us
yes it says three and mine says one okay
so what you guys have to do is that one
of you will be playing at a time okay
and well the other person is not playing
you have to be giving sports commentary
okay what time - and you switch every
point okay now is this this is not a
ball no I can take that what I have to
do is catch
thank you [ __ ] she's good at one sport I
know she's dedicate her life to one
thing and it's foosball uh-huh okay so I
have whining commands back together so I
have to play the entire match with my
hands but you're still gonna win okay
let's see here we go
what's our game two five okay what
timing I feel honored to have you guys
here to make commentary I love it this
is what we do perfect yeah professional
that's who we are okay
Oh actually would you like to start
onii-chan starting okay are you ready
yes okay now you're gonna go behind your
back oh yeah [ __ ] if some of us have
to follow the rules and other people
don't
we're okay here we go we're a society
based on rules guys we have a perfect
day weather-wise for foosball and you
can't ask for anything better than it
exactly Kelsey moving the ball around
very well
Randy having trouble once again she's
behind her back she's passing it to the
black guy and she scores
yep this is what we excuses she's
passing it to the black guy yes yes
always switch switch okay okay
Jason's trained a long time for this
he is clearly has the wrist surgery has
not affected him that much he's in a
contract year Oh
goal
okay relax easy easy
once I didn't expect this tour once all
of high school and right now is better
than junior high okay score tied 1-1
Kelsey we need she passes the ball
across midfield and she's having trouble
but she gets it up to a striker and
Randy scores turns out this is a
challenge this is what we needed her to
be severely handing that's right we're
good when the other person is that a
severe disadvantage and there's two of
us that's the story of our lives
okay Jason's got a ball at center ring
he's got it and he really rips it as
hard as he can but I guarantee she's
gonna score right here oh nice save by
the goalie lays out Oh Oh big shot Jason
not understanding what which of those
things he needs to use except the two
guy his own guy blocked at all Oh Jay it
3-1 you do not want to be at this much
of a disadvantage against to quote
Montell Jordan the dish is how we do it
and that was for him in his dish
commercial why did he do a dish course
Wow like it does me proud
I had such low expectations for
ourselves I literally thought we'd be
shut out every time this is really hard
there it is that's not that hard Randy
proving once again that it's not as hard
as we think Jason is stepping up to the
center square it's the gay square as we
OH
as he kicks along the back lines nice
block by Kelsey she's she's really
cooking now and which is the name of her
cookbook it's a cookbook all with table
soccer nice Jay
oh boy she's gonna win she is going to
win just three three all knotted up team
Squire heaven so four three three it's
up to Jason to shut the door right now
point yet no put it on the door right
now who is severely handicapped match
okay can he do it can't you this is
really hard what she's trying to do
behind the back yeah behind the back
politics okay here it comes
she's gonna look in this for oh he's
looking to know what I'm doing okay I
really don't know what I'm doing he does
not know he's doing he slides it on the
two-man blocked by the five guy she's
moving it on the five guys looking she
comes gonna score right here you know
she's gonna score she wants it so badly
she wants it more than Jason wants it
this is not good for anybody's back this
is not good for scoliosis not good for
America golf off walk oh it is not it
does not fill us with any prize like
this is really the most hollow victory
that this person in all of sports is the
most loss of a victory that we could
ever have but this is like when Michigan
beat Rutgers recently that's like you
can't even celebrate like don't play the
fight song do not sing Rutgers is Kelsey
either arms I'm gonna turn all of my men
upside down because just in mourning for
what we just did like literally like
what we just did is the reason why and
I'm not just saying this because of
these players on your team this is why
black lives matter that's it
what we just why black foots on foot SOT
and fault whatever their color is ball
matter lives matter
and in reference to Eric garner said I
can't breathe and that happens okay okay
are we doing one more you're
legitimately mad are you really mad for
real
do you even win all of those usually you
always win those usually and I've lost a
couple now because we keep making it
harder and weirder and I tell you why
that feels better for me is that because
it was one on one each time it wasn't
the two of us against you so there is a
part of me that says because I think a
lot of people in general look we always
say this about being a comedy team the
best part about being comedy team is
that we get to split the money but also
you people start to see you as part of
this unit and can you do it on your own
can you be funny on your own can't you
be a woman who is a foosball champion a
table soccer champion without slide on
your back right can you do it on your
own and the answer is yes and we didn't
see his point
we barely did it it's like that guy when
Roy Moore like won by like when Roy when
Roy Moore lost in Alabama by like 0.5%
all the Democrats were like we did we
beat was that was known as Neal Brennan
famously said if we can beat a known
child molester by 0.8 of a point
anybody's probably can do anything
anything is possible
[Music]
okay well I'm glad you guys are talking
about
sports rivalries big Michigan State sure
against a huge I apologize Wow they
almost shot me no well Michigan State is
a different I mean it's a great school
if you support the work of Larry Nasser
yes it's a great school of you want to
protect players they've sexually
harassed people or stolen computers it's
wonderful yeah good out of your cultural
school but beside that yeah okay
so what's gonna happen now we're gonna
play a game of two ball okay where we
each start with the ball okay we say one
two three go we hit it on go and you
have to score both balls to get one
point okay gotcha if we each score one
it's a wash first person to five wins if
you guys lose you have to sing the Ohio
State I don't know that I owe state fun
let's pull it up for you but you guys
have to really and you have to commit I
don't want it like any like half-ass us
I'm feeling okay I'm a die-hard I can't
do it here's my question
if you sing that song you become a date
rapist I'm afraid to do it we're just
thinking of women and our wives yeah
okay all right so what happens if you
score two that's just one point
yeah score both is this gonna take like
four hours I am NOT gonna sing this song
with any emotion I will be dead inside
I'm just telling you I'll do it and that
is just me saying those words is gonna
make me hate everything that I'm doing
and then after this we're going to Yom
Kippur services and I'm going to
apologize to God and everyone and I will
not eat for 24 hours as a result of
singing this song and it's also you have
to go back and forth a couple times or
no no we do one two three when I say go
we both have it okay better yeah one two
three go
thanks man nice okay who's won she's mad
because we beat she's there anything for
them to like no she's mad cuz we beat
her one two three go what are the Ohio
State colors oh I don't know red and
white red and yeah red in the colors of
what's the jail color orange yeah that's
what it is hey one two three go man I
feel like you guys are really do that
yeah it's really coming alive that I can
feel like no you really do not you
really don't want to do do not want to
sing this song I hate Ohio State eight
one two three go nice to
wait that one went in right did go in
okay take wow so we are getting so close
one more point I do not want to sing
this song at all you know when people
have lost recently I refuse to thing
listen how the meat dog treats and I
feel like you guys would honestly rather
I would rather I will lead a dog treat I
do know I will do dog treats over that I
can't I literally cannot unfortunately
the way I don't know you guys don't have
any other I don't you know the I don't
know the tune to of it I'm going to say
it in the deadest voice that I possibly
can alright one two three go No damn it
every time I get coffee I never make it
nice Jack good give it right to her you
say this like I because we beat you in
yeah you did get beat let's be honest
you didn't I got beat one game but I
beat you overall oh yeah a bit us
overall damn banker Coco's two dumb
peoples that town asked us if we would
score twice Dan didn't think we'd score
twice well we didn't me okay so there's
lyrics going across the screen I want
you guys to sing you know loud improv
not gonna be loud we're not gonna be
loud but we're gonna cheap seated as we
do it
the worst man in old Ohio Columbus
there's a team that's known throughout
the land they felt throughout wrong
eleven a re rave involved with a family
lever stand and when the ball goes over
our cheer sky and we will support a
woman a man who hits his wife we had a
battle cry if you're a coach and you
hate your wife will support you yes we
will will slow down for you wear the
scarlet in gray we don't care if we pay
every player come on to Ohio smash
through to victory well two years ago
the honors have been we will defend
anyone who hits their wife ballgame Wow
that even saying half of those words
makes my skin crawl
I wish I knew how to play foosball
better yeah who's gonna make me want to
learn how to do things yeah my life so
this is this really gonna have like a
lasting negative it's like more than
eating a dog treat wood oh yeah a tree
when I was a kid I used to eat Gaines
burgers I'm like those look good they
look yummy that looks like a good little
burger and it was because the people at
Gaines burger while I'm sure they did
some terrible things they do not pay
their players they do not support
coaches who hit their wives and all that
stuff all right well where people can
find you
you can see our podcast or listen to our
podcast dumb people town and you can see
it if you watch your earbuds that's
right why you know there's some video
stuff yeah and we're your new YouTube
channel for dumb people town subscribe
to that we will be out live yes just go
to super sklar's calm and you can see
all of our dates where we're gonna be
live because we have a bunch of live
dates coming up in the next like six
months or so also catch them at Ohio
State football game coming up
cheering section will be the ones just
arresting everyone because there's so
many people to arrest in that crooked
audience got the cops down yeah I know
citizen's arrest yeah exactly police
Academy's stick them in Stadium jail you
guys can follow me on instagram at
Kelsey cook comedy Twitter's at kelsey
cook website is Kelsey cook calm for
tour dates and please make sure you
subscribe to the all things comedy
youtube channel and go check out the new
wrist of fury episodes thank you guys so
much thank you guys are amazing thank
you guys we'll see you next time
[Music]